well that didn't last long on January
1st Mitt Romney a man so stiff you could
earn his shirt on him that's the
president in The Washington Post
remember that you know the drill Trump's
Rudy lacks character and so on it could
have been ridden on January 1st 2018 or
2017 or he'll 1517 if the definition of
insanity is complaining about something
that will never change MIT's finally
made it to the loony bin and he was
helped by a media acting like that blast
from the past who indulges unhappy exes
seem it's still mad about Trump and the
Washington Post and CNN will let him cry
on their shoulder as long as it's done
in public and that he pays for the
dry-cleaning it's tempting for MIT it
feels good to get hugs from a media that
once branded you a sexist bully who
hurts dogs and kept women in binders a
press that joined Obama's dry laugh when
MIT said just maybe Russia is a problem
but this attention is just strange new
respect that's gone by tomorrow the
media may pretend to like you because
you hate Trump but they're just using
you don't forget the media was brutal to
MIT too as they are to anyone right of a
Castro and if Trump hadn't won had it
been Rubio or Bush you think they would
have been spared Jeb would be called a
war monger and Rubio a misogynist to the
press the only acceptable Republican is
an ex Republican his name is Joe
Scarborough and nobody cares
so mitt that warm glow you feel from the
left isn't true love it's a bug zapper
they'll pull you in as long as you dis
Trump but only until it's time for them
to fry your ass so Jessie welcome back
thank you
theories on this why is he doing this I
thought it's because he's gonna
challenge Trump but then I heard that he
said on CNN that he has no interest in
that yeah I mean he might flip-flop on
that he has flip-flopped in the past I
mean we get it mit you have great
character drink milk you don't curse
like it's clear you're a Mormon you go
to church every Sunday you're perfect we
get that you're cut you're becoming a
scold now though a little bit and it's
turning people off the guy you know and
I voted for him and two primaries in 20
in 2008 in in 2012 of the Republican
primaries but he just says all
word political instincts and he does
things in self-serving ways I think
remember he like changed his position on
abortion the individual mandate
immigration in the 1980s he says he
wasn't a Reagan Republican I I think at
one point he was pro Trump than he was
anti Trump and things keep changing look
at what happened when he ran against
Barack Obama I mean he let this guy
smear his business acumen coming from
Barack Obama who is an economic
illiterate let that get away and then
what did not go for the jugular and the
debate over Benghazi when he had him on
the ropes and let that slide and his
timing is terrible it's like he dusts it
off a never Trump op-ed from the summer
of 2016 and send it off to the to the
newspaper this guy is he's not trying to
primary Donald Trump you're joining a
club the Senate is a club you're trying
to get along and he's making it about
himself and I know Mitch McConnell
sitting there rolling his eyes watching
Romney coming in hot dog on the first
day I mean while these guys you know
just confirm or Cavanaugh's keep the
government open and build the wall
that's all that voters really care about
all right so Danny Marie I want to get
you in but first can i play Donald
Trump's response to Mitt Romney from
today I wish MIT could be more of a team
player you know I'm surprised he did it
this quickly I was expecting something
but I'm surprised he did it this quickly
but I am surprised because we've done a
lot and he actually says it I read his
up it if he fought really hard against
President Obama like he does against me
he would have won the election all right
and I'm sure you have very very soft
opinions about this topic I'm pretty
pissed about this yes what a fraud I
mean I don't know about if you've the
Twitter thing but I was on Twitter on
the plane yeah like on the plane
filleting this this fraud you know it
character so let me get this straight he
goes out he viciously attacks Donald
Trump in that initial speech after by
the way seeking his support when he was
running for president filets them in
this disingenuous speech then goes and
goes up to Bedminster and goes up for an
interview for a cabinet position then
has the famous dinner in New York in
other words all of a sudden this guy he
had character with when a job was
sitting in front of him this big phone
this guy's a total hoax he's the biggest
fraud in politics what does he do he
immediately no I'm sorry he is and he
deserves to be called out for the fraud
that he is he what you wanted a job once
you could catch a paycheck and some
power back from the president and by the
way who has more character after Trump
got filleted by this idiot on in this
speech I'm sorry because I'm really
pissed about this because I'm tired of
this guy because he represents every
single thing wrong with me swamp rodents
that have screwed up the country that
only care about the darn selves I'm
sorry he has this guy's a clown no one
should take this guy seriously he's a
joke Trump gave him a second and a third
chance and he still screwed him over in
the end that's the kind of guy Romney is
all right Murray I know you agree with
everything Dan just said so we could
just skip I'll go to Kennedy the
challenge is Donald Trump actually needs
to care what Mitt Romney thinks because
he needs every vote in the Senate to
keep confirming judges like Jesse is so
focused on and he actually will need
every Republican vote I think that Mitt
Romney who I sort of you know I worked
on the 2012 campaign all of my friend
from that campaign are like God now we
have to talk about Mitt Romney again we
thought we dealt with that six years ago
but you know he I think genuinely
believes this he is a person who seems
to be from afar a good person a family
man someone who has morals and cares
about them in public life and they
didn't say that when you're running
against him you will not be able to find
a quote for me that talks about his
character and I think that he genuinely
believes this and the bigger point Dan
isn't whether or not you like what he's
saying or if this is the right thing to
do and quite frankly I don't care what
he writes in an op-ed I care what he
does in the Senate and so for
Republicans you all will care if he
votes with Trump for Democrats we will
care if he stands up to Trump like Jeff
Flake at times did bob Corker at times
did but Republicans should not you
should take these voices in the party
seriously they have genuine arguments
with the president's behavior they're
not ridiculous argument it's but no but
the biggest okay Kennedy the behavior
that he's referring to is now going on
its third year we've all kind of grips
with it we now look at the deeds and not
the words and I and Romney was saying oh
he had a bad month to a lot of people it
was a good month because he's pulling
2,000 troops out of Syria I mean there
are people that believe that is actually
a good month yeah and there are people
who believe that that will show that we
shouldn't be in the Middle East
first place but let's talk about Mitt
Romney because that's all Mitt Romney
wants to do right now and to any
incoming freshman senator I would say
put up and shut up you know we don't
really want to hear about your feelings
and how you have the vapors and you're
offended by someone's narcissism whose
behavior really hasn't changed but the
interesting thing about Mitt Romney is
you could argue that President Trump is
a result of Mitt Romney's failure
because politics especially when it
comes to the presidency tends to be a
reaction the pendulum swings and you
have very opposite people especially
after a two-term president who inhabit
the White House all you have to do is
look at you know Clinton to bush and
this is just in the modern era and then
to Obama Obama was the opposite of
George W Bush for a lot of people even
independents and some Republicans and
now Donald Trump is the exact opposite
of President Obama if Mitt Romney had
won in 2012
there wouldn't be a president Trump
right now and and that's what he has to
internalize and if you have a problem
with him and and this is where I have a
little bit more respect for people like
Lindsey Graham and Rand Paul go with
specifics if you have a policy issue
talk about that and dissect it because
that's where you can have the big room
because Graham and Trump never got along
remember they have each other in the
primary and Trump I think gave a
cellphone number outside yeah and out
Graham's dining with the president
almost every day they're like petroleum
into policy changes because you know
what you got it
Trump like sugar if you're gonna
antagonize them like the flakes and the
k-6 and the Romney's you're just gonna
get punched in the mouth and it's gonna
get ugly if you try to you know warm up
to them and trying to move them in the
right direction it doesn't work either
grandma's had no impact on Donald
Trump's foreign policies at all
I disagree look at what happened with
Syria now he's easing the withdrawal
what's he's actually committed a lot
less after he spoke to Graham let's see
if he does but the Republican Party is
in the a an inflection point as is the
Democratic Party and if there isn't room
for a Mitt Romney and Donald Trump's
party that is a problem national no the
party has passed him though I mean I
would argue that the party has passed
establishment Republicans like Mitt
Romney it is a constant evolution right
that's the other thing you know it's
like the Nancy Pelosi's of the world
stand in stark contrast to the Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez's
you'll see that's right maybe it doesn't
mean that the new generation is better
than the one they're passing but that's
how the system works all right
the one thing I wanted to talk about we
don't have time is how Trump has an
effect on everybody's family it disrupts
families and again even with MIT's
family with his niece what's-her-name
Rana Rana coming out and and basically
saying calling him up I think calling
him a first-time Democrat incoming yes